in the introduction to your book on
trauma
Lady Gaga wrote it she wrote the forward
the intro
she said this about you quote I can now
say with certainty that this man saved
my life
he made life worth living this goes to
our discussion about uh the uh the
Mythic Sisyphus kamu question about why
I live
so I think at least to me she's one of
the most brilliant and unique artists
ever so
it's a difficult question but a question
of creativity what role does trauma play
in um
in somebody like that in this artist
that has created some incredible things
uh what positive constructive
um
a role does trauma serve and what
limiting role does it serve in
preventing that person from flourishing
more trauma can certainly drive us to
creativity right the two even to push
again so to protest against what the
trauma tells us you know trauma tells us
lessons like nothing matters and you
don't matter and nothing will ever be
good and then nothing is beautiful and
and we can push against trauma they know
there is life in me there's something
there's goodness for me to to spread in
the world to express and spread so I
think trauma fuels creativity in many
many many ways trauma also shuts down
creativity right of people who are for
it's one example a trauma that escalates
to the point where now the person is
soothing it with alcohol it's one
example and now the impact of the
alcohol shuts down any creativity so so
can people be creative and outward
thinking without trauma I think
sometimes if I remember correctly people
will use Emmanuel Kant as an example of
someone I think hadn't traveled much and
didn't have trauma and like look at what
he knew so okay they're going to be
exceptions right but a lot of our
creativity is in some ways fueled by our
suffering although it's complicated
because it comes from generative places
in us right so those places are there
they're not created by suffering but
maybe suffering makes an incentive or a
passion inside of us and and a person
you know Stephanie who you referred to
is just such an incredible astounding
creative force and sure some of that
comes from trauma some of it comes from
you know trauma fueling degenerative
creative places in her but what I helped
her to do she's very generous with her
words but but what I helped her to do
was to see all that she is and all that
the creativity in her is and all that
there is to to create through love and
caring and uh compassion and and to
again see that I mean a lot of time
that's that's what I'm doing clinically
settings with a good psychiatrists or
mental health professionals do is we
help people see the beauty that is there
right because oftentimes we're way too
close up to that tapestry and what
brings us close is often the sad thing
so we're up close in all we see is the
negative I mean it's easy then to get
classically nihilistic but by helping
someone take a step back and to see who
they are and what's in them that's how
people get better and how people
re-engage in in life it's such a
difficult thing because if you were to
for studying human beings
it seems like the optimal trajectory
is having some trauma that doesn't
destroy you
that forces you early in life to really
struggle with the intricacies of The
Human Condition
and then later in life as you form and
like you build an expertise around and
mastery
start to do exactly what you said would
you step back and look at the tapestry
so if you if if uh if you don't have the
trauma it seems like just empirically
speaking there's of course just a huge
amount of data and all kinds of
anecdotal evidence but it and I'm I want
to be careful here because maybe I'm
romanticizing
uh hardship
but it does seem that hardship and
childhood
if it doesn't break you can be
constructive it's like like you said
having that trauma one of the ways to
fight it is to say I am worth something
right I am and this is you know
um David Goggins talks about this is
like this is um
I am somebody I I can't be somebody
special and I'm gonna prove it to you
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this big
thing it's this engine that drives you
forward yeah comment on that because
like from a like a parent's perspective
you want
a child to have an easy life
right you want them to uh not have
hardship certainly not have trauma
but that's such a difficult dance
because
um in some ways a little bit of hardship
in a gradually increasing amount of
hardship that doesn't break you can
really develop you into a really
interesting complicated
um person and it helps you flourish as a
creative being I don't know what the I
don't know I don't know if there's a
question I'll just keep running saying
random things no it makes look I think
it makes good yeah it makes good sense
to me I think you're trying to get at
like we need trauma and like and what
and how are we defining it right because
we say trauma hardship difficulties I
mean we could set aside we could we
could set apart say and differentiate
things that are difficult but that are
overcomeable right yeah versus things
that we could use trauma the word trauma
this way if we if we chose to that are
just like entirely negative like like
someone saying oh
you can't do that and you'll never
succeed because well and then they tell
you something about yourself okay
because you're from here you're this
race religion whatever it is right we
think well you know it could that could
make someone say hey I'm going to show
you I'm going to overcome right but then
they're overcoming something bad right
like it's just like there's nothing good
or helpful about that right if someone's
saying that so the person has to
overcome it that's different than
something that is placed in front of a
person where where the whole conception
of it is something positive that you can
make through effort right so you know I
remember how do I think I was 15 years
old there's some rule like we you could
then go I don't think was picking
raspberries or blueberries right and I
think and my parents wanted me to see
like okay let's go see how that works
here now you got 50 cents at the end of
it right and then you think about that
when you know you want to buy baseball
cards or you you know you think about it
and you you work hard and I could
remember like it was hard and I was
sweating and I was tired and but I
learned from it I mean so the reason I
remember it today so so yes parents
might want their kids to have like a
good life right but not necessarily an
easy life you know and I think that was
done they took me to do that to so I
have a greater sense of responsibility
in a sense of like hard work is
Meaningful and it's important and and I
think that that kind of thing is good
but if we separate that from something
that's just denigrating prejudicial like
I think those things aren't good but
they're unavoidable so it's not
necessarily that always some trauma good
I would look at it more that some trauma
is unavoidable I mean you know it's hard
to how do you go through life and not
have any losses or anything negative or
anything sad and then people are people
there may be people who have not a lot
of that and then there's a sort of
complacency or and they don't do it as
much as they could or feel as good as
they could you know then there's other
people who have a highly attuned
emotional it's the people with very
highly attuned emotional compasses for
which a little bit of trauma becomes so
intrusive so it's so much of it is
person driven but I do want to
distinguish between things that are just
purely bad add that we might overcome or
find some fire in our belly about or
whatever the case may be and things that
maybe boundaries or barriers either
directly purposely placed or not that in
a sense invite us or or inform us of the
possibility of striving and overcoming
finally in tuned emotional compasses
it's so true that there is uh
that's a component of it too it's
there's almost genetic
how sensitive you are to particular
trauma so little things can have a huge
impact or gigantic things uh serious
abuse in in childhood can be by some
people overcome more easily right so
it's not just what's the trauma because
what's the trauma that makes certain
problems you have to match the trauma to
the person and a big part of what you're
matching to is that you know genetically
based characteristic of how finely
attuned is that
empathic Attunement to that compass